(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] This is the
Gooty Sapphire tarantula,
also known as the Poecilotheria metallica.
Their exotic blue color comes from
tiny hairs that line their bodies,
making the Gooty Sapphire one of
the most beautiful species
of tarantula in the world.
The Gooty Sapphire tarantula lives
in the forest of East Gooty,
India, hence their name.
They are very quick and can defend
themselves if they feel threatened.
They are extremely venomous.
One bite from them can pack a huge punch,
causing humans excruciating
pain that can last over a week.
The Gooty Sapphire tarantula is
classified as critically endangered
because they only live
in a single small area,
which is now being harvested for firewood,
leading to the loss of their only habitat.
This is the Gooty Sapphire tarantula.
(dramatic music)